The Sun is just one of hundreds
of billions of stars in our galaxy.
In a way, there’s nothing
very special about it.
It’s a fairly ordinary star -
not particularly large or bright
by stellar standards.
But it’s very special to us.
The Sun makes life on Earth possible.
Cultures across the world,
and throughout the ages,
worshipped the sun.
In some ways, modern life
has cut us off from the Sun.
In the developed world we spend
90% of our time indoors –
and yet the Sun is still a powerful
force underpinning our lives.
The Sun affects our perception
of beauty.
When people talk of the
“golden hour”,
that time just before the Sun
sets, it’s a real thing.
The Sun isn’t actually yellow
or orange or even red.
It’s all the colours mixed together.
When the Sun rises or sets
in the sky, the shortwave colours -
green, blue and violet -
are scattered,
leaving only the yellow and
the red part of the spectrum,
giving that amazing glow.
When the Sun is high in the sky,
its blue waves bounce around –
which is why the sky looks blue.
And when you see a rainbow,
that’s the light
from the sun separated
into all its magnificent colours.
Although we talk of the Sun rising
in the east and setting in the west,
that’s not quite true.
It just seems that way to us.
The Sun stays in the same place.
It’s the Earth
that rotates on its axis.
This movement of the Sun is deeply
embedded in our biology.
When sunlight enters the eye,
it sends signals
to a master clock in our brain
called the suprachiasmatic nucleus.
This internal clock
regulates everything,
from when we sleep
to how we digest a meal.
Messing with this
finely-tuned machine,
when we work night shifts
or fly across the world,
can make us feel pretty rough.
Even the bluish light from a mobile
phone late at night
is enough to disrupt
and confuse our internal body clock.
Being out of step with the Sun
affects our mood
and our ability to think clearly.
And there’s evidence
that this kind of disruption
can lead to higher rates of obesity,
heart disease,
diabetes and even cancer.
We’re living out of step with the Sun
and some scientists say this could
be causing a public health crisis.
When the sun is shining,
studies have shown that
we tip more generously
and are more likely
to splash out on luxury goods.
And crime may go down too.
One study in the US
found that when the clocks
go forward for Daylight Savings Time,
the number of robberies, rapes
and murders went down around 50%.
The Sun is a hell of a force
to be reckoned with.
Every hour,
enough sunlight falls on the
earth to power the world for a year.
Deep in its core, at around
15 million degrees Celsius,
the Sun is constantly fusing hydrogen
together to make helium.
These nuclear reactions
release vast amounts of energy
in the form of sunlight.
If only we could work out
how to harness this.
But we are getting there.
It’s estimated that by 2022,
30% of our energy could
come from renewables,
with solar growing faster
than anything else.
The Sun is vast, dynamic…
and sometimes violent.
Viewed up close, the Sun’s surface
looks like a raging sea of fire,
with huge eruptions
rising hundreds of thousands
of kilometres into space.
There are even earthquakes
on the Sun – called sunquakes.
And what happens on the Sun
can impact us.
The Sun sporadically blasts huge
clouds of charged particles
towards the Earth,
potentially wreaking havoc on the
technology that we all rely on.
But 97% of people have never
heard of solar storms.
In 1859,
a gigantic solar storm hit the Earth,
creating auroras that
covered the entire planet,
knocking out the telegraph network
and sending sparks flying
from electrical equipment.
The solar storm of 1859
is still the largest on record.
But if a similar storm
were to hit the Earth today,
the consequences for our way
of life could be devastating,
knocking out electricity grids,
satellite navigation
and communications
for days, weeks…
or even months.
No wonder people used
to worship the sun.